Russia’s Jewish community has been watching
the war in Ukraine with mounting alarm.
But most have kept silent fearing state
reprisals if they spoke out against the Kremlin.
And yet as the fighting intensified
a senior figure in the community felt
that silence was immoral. So he fled
Moscow after 30 years as the city’s
Chief Rabbi in order to speak freely
- and he joins me now from Berlin.
He’s Pinchas Goldschmidt, President of
the Conference of European Rabbis and
he wants all Jews in Russia
to get out now. His reasons?
It is a) the rise in antisemitism,
b) the possibility of the closing
of the iron curtain, that it is
going to be impossible to leave.
Number three are the harder-hitting sanctions
which are going to damage the economy long term.
In Conflict Zone this week we ask
if Ukraine’s president Volodymyr
Zelenskyy was right to criticize
Israel’s response to the war.
Should Jews speak out whenever
universal values are threatened?
And will historians look back on this war as a
wrong turning for Russia – or
the start of a new, dark age?
----------
Rabbi Pinchas Goldschmidt,
welcome to Conflict Zone.
Tim, thank you for having me on your program.
It's good to see you. Your initial response to the
February invasion, if I can start with that, the
February invasion of Ukraine, was basically to say
nothing. Not to support it, not to condemn it. In
order, you said, not to get the Jewish community
into trouble. Do you regret that initial response?
Considering the shock of every
single member of the community,
and I think many of the citizens in Russia,
of the actual invasion, most people actually
thought that nothing is going to happen. I sat
the day before with many diplomats and members
of parliament and others, and they said: Oh,
who needs Ukraine? We don't need Ukraine.
And so it was a shock and it took time till it
registered that we are in here for an all-out war.
You said later you realized keeping quiet in such
circumstances is morally wrong. And yet
that was the clear choice you made in
the immediate aftermath of the invasion.
I'm wondering why, was it out of habit?
It was-, we got, I would say, in the last years of
the current regime, we in the community basically
we're like the whole of Russian society,
we're depoliticized. Which means we did not
comment on political issues and we did not
get involved in politics in order not to get
into trouble. Because if you support one way
or you do the other way, if you don't support the
regime, then you have problems. However, as the-,
we understood that we're dealing here with a
European war. With millions of refugees and
Jewish communities which are being destroyed after
being so difficult to rebuild after the communist
regime, after the breakup of the Soviet Union. I
came to the realization, and not everyone, I'm-,
I want to say this openly, that not only can we
stay silent, we have to do something about it.
So in that case, have recent events in Russia
and your response to them compelled you to
rethink your attitude to morality? What is a
moral response to an invasion of this kind?
No, I don't think that-, I think that since the
changes which have happened in Russia had been,
I would say, gradual, it has not been from
one day to the next. So it was difficult
to pinpoint to the moment that you had to say,
enough is enough. I cannot stay silent anymore.
And however, the change, the major change in
the country of waking up to 24th of February
in the morning and seeing with mass arrests and
every last independent media being shut down,
we understood that this was a major change and we
live in a different country with different rules.
You say you were living in a different country,
but you lived in a country where President Putin
had invaded and occupied Crimea in 2014.
He’d fueled a war in the Donbass where some
15,000 people had died. So February 24th was
a continuation of what had gone before, wasn't
it? It was fully in line with the trajectory
that this administration had been following:
expanding Russia's borders, clamping down on
civil liberties at home, and killing enough
political opponents for the rest to get the
idea. That much had to be clear, wasn't it?
Yes. First of all, when-, with the Crimea,
not one person died during the
takeover of the Crimea. And, you know-
Does that make it ok?
…I could throw the question back to you. Where was
Europe? Where was the United States? And with-,
why didn't they push all these very punishing
sanctions in 2014? Why did they wait till 2022?
Good question. And we put the question to them.
But I'm asking you, were you not aware that
rights and universal rights were being trampled
and people were being repressed and
killed in Russia during that period.
It was-, I would say that, number one, the
people who were repressed was on a smaller scale.
And Tim, I want to tell you that
the red line between a democracy
and authoritarianism is not always clear. And
when you pass from one system to the other,
it's not always clear when is the red line passed?
So is it when there are no more free elections,
or is it when some people critical of the regime
are being jailed? It's not always clear that-,
you know, and you have quite a few countries where
you pass from a democracy to an authoritarianism
and then to totalitarianism. Are the lines clear?
The lines are not always clear. Only in hindsight.
Is there a lesson that you took away
from this, that staying silent is not
an option where universal rights are being
trampled and people are being repressed?
I think that in today's situation
where a country has been invaded and there are
millions and millions of refugees leaving this
country it is very important for everyone to
speak up. Everyone who can. Not everyone can.
Looking back, do you think if more people had
spoken up, and you talked about the Western
reaction - you threw the question back
to me as if I was talking for the West,
I'm not actually talking for the West.
But if more people had spoken out,
both in Russia and around the world, do
you think that President Putin might not
have gone ahead with the full-scale
invasion he launched in February?
I tend to think that if somebody would
have told on the 23rd of February
to the Kremlin that the reaction of the West,
of Europe, the United States is going to be the
one we have seen, I highly doubt that the
Kremlin would have gone on with this war.
So is the Jewish community in Russia
now rethinking the practice of staying
silent and keeping their head down and
trying to stay out of trouble? Should it?
You know as well as I am, as I do, that people
who speak up are being fined or being arrested.
The businesses are being closed down. So
it is very easy to criticize the Russian
regime from the safety of London or
Paris or Berlin. It is much harder
to do it if you live inside Russia, your
business is there, you have parents there,
you have children there. So it's much easier
to talk about it than actually to do it.
But Rabbi Goldschmidt,
making the right moral decision can't
always be a cost-free exercise, can it?
Take-, Yes, it is-, Every person has
a free choice and every person has
to take the right decision. So
I'm concerned about the future
of the Jewish community in Russia, and
I'm not the only one concerned. Thousands
and tens of thousands of Jews have left the
country since the beginning of the invasion.
And should those who stayed-
And I think that by leaving they have-,
I'm sure that by leaving they-, everyone
who left the country made a statement.
And should those who've left the country,
what should their attitude be now?
Should they speak out? Should they
say whatever they need to say?
I think that everyone who
has the possibility has to
state and has to say what he thinks, what
she thinks. And speaking to hundreds and
thousands of members of my community and also
of Russians of other religions, I feel that in
speaking with the people outside of Russia, I
feel there is very little support for this war.
A prominent politician, former minister
Natan Sharansky, who was, as you know,
a dissident who was jailed in
the Soviet Union - a refusenik,
as they were called at the time - he says that
if Jews have the chance to get out of Russia,
they should take it. They should
go. Do you support that view?
Yes, I support this view and for many
reasons. And the many reasons why Jews
today are concerned about the future in Russia
it is a) the rise in antisemitism, b) the
possibility of a closing of the iron curtain
that it is going to be impossible to leave.
Number three are the harder-hitting sanctions
which are going to damage the economy long
term. And number four the possibility of
that there's going to be a general draft
for the Army and number five is the
widening repression of civil society.
Let me, if I may, take you back to
the time when you made the decision
in March to leave Russia. You said that after two
weeks soul searching, you left because you wanted
to be able to speak out against the war, and you'd
been told the Jewish community would suffer if you
did that and stayed. Can you clear up exactly what
threats were aimed at you personally and by whom?
I think that it was not only the possibility
of speaking out. Speaking out is important,
but as you know, Judaism is a religion of deeds.
It's not only a religion of thoughts or beliefs.
It is the actual deed which is important for us.
And we call this deed the mitzvah. And speaking
out has been secondary. First and most important
has been the feeling and the realization that
we have to do something to help those thousands
of refugees of our communities who had to leave
to Eastern Europe, which was with maybe with one
suitcase, who didn't have a roof on their heads.
And that's what we did. We established under the
aegis of the Conference of European Rabbis this
fund, an international fund to help Ukrainian
refugees. And I've been visiting, I left Russia
to visit in Eastern European capitals, in
Budapest, in Warsaw and also in Romania,
all those thousands of Jewish refugees and
other refugees who went there. And we have
established programs for the integration and for
the help of those refugees. So speaking out has
been secondary. The number one mitzvah or the
number one deed, which we had to do is to help.
My question was about the threats that
you personally received. How graphic,
how clear were these threats?
I think if you are a clergyman
living in a certain country,
you can identify, you understand when
you're getting messages from certain
quarters. And it doesn't always have to
be personal, it can be communal as well.
So what was said to you and by whom?
I don't want to go into more details. There
are still many members of the community
living in Russia continuing to work there
with people in the clergy. We have rabbis,
we have community leaders. At this
moment, I don't want to go into details.
One or two Jewish leaders in Russia
did speak out and did refuse to tow
the official line. Couldn't you have
done the same and stayed in Russia?
It's-, I don't think that I would have
been-, I don't think I would have been
able to help and to establish this whole
structure to help refugees staying in
Russia. And I don't think I would have
been able to communicate to the world,
to the Jewish world, and to the world at large
the issues and the challenges we are facing.
Did leaving Russia feel in
any way like running away?
I think that if I've been the only one
making this decision, maybe you're right.
I'm-, I can tell you one thing. I have a very good
friend. She's one of the leading journalists in
the opposition. And initially she was quite upset
that I left. But a month later, she left herself.
So you felt vindicated?
It's not a question of feeling vindicated.
It is a question of today we have tens of
thousands of members of my community who are
living outside Russia. I would say if we're
talking about people who used to come to our
synagogues, I would say even the majority is
outside of Russia. My community is all over the
world. They are in Dubai, they are in Israel,
they are in London and in Germany. And
the immigration to Israel from Russia was
twice as high than from Ukraine in the last-,
since the war started. And I'm responsible for
the wider community. And I also believe
that I'll be able to help our community,
which stayed on in Russia better from
the outside than from the inside.
Rabbi Goldschmidt, it seems that relations between
senior Jewish figures in Russia and Ukraine have
been badly damaged by the events in recent months.
In March, Ukraine's Chief Rabbi, Moshe Azman,
roundly condemned leaders of the Russian Jewish
community and said your failure to denounce the
invasion was tantamount to complicity. How
hard is it going to be to repair those ties?
I don't know. There were some leaders
who supported the invasion. I don't
want to express myself, I don't want
to judge them. Who am I to judge? I
can tell you that my relationship with
our Ukrainian colleagues is wonderful.
And did you call Rabbi Azman? He says-, when
he said: ‘I'm talking to you, dear Russians,
dear Jews. Remember that one who is indifferent
is an accomplice to war crimes, crimes against
humanity. I stand with the Holy Torah and I
tell you to wake up.' Hardly anyone, he said,
has called me. Do you understand the sense of
abandonment that he had from the Jewish community?
I for sure, I for sure can feel it.
Ukraine doesn't have only one Chief Rabbi,
by the way. You know, we have quite-, we have, I
think, three Chief Rabbis in Ukraine and we are
in touch with them. And I myself just three
weeks ago spent a whole long weekend in the
town of Neptun in Romania with 1200 refugees
from Odessa, with the Chief Rabbi of Odesa.
So we are in touch with our colleagues from
Ukraine. And I also spoke a few days ago to
a group of new immigrants from Russia and Ukraine
in Jerusalem. And you had over there in the room,
you had about 40 or 50 young people. And they
came from Moscow, from other cities in Russia
and from Odesa and from Kyiv and from Mykolaiv,
even from Mariupol. And you should see those
people just sitting together trying to help each
other in the new country. They all left their
countries of origins, not because they wanted
to, but because of the impossibility to stay.
Talking of helping Ukrainians, President
Zelenskyy, himself a Jew, has had harsh words
for what he sees as Israel's inadequate response
to the conflict. To Israel's mediation efforts
he said there can be no mediation between
good and evil. He has a point, doesn't he?
I want to tell you, those people who
want to criticize Israel for not going-,
not joining Europe with sanctions
against Russia. I want to remind them that Israel
is not buying oil and gas from Russia. Israel is
not financing the war. It is Europe buying gas and
oil from Russia, is financing the war in Russia.
Some of that criticism, Rabbi Goldschmidt,
has come from inside Israel itself. The former
Prime Minister, Ehud Olmert, for instance.
He didn't think much of the government's
reaction in February. There are times, he
said, when you have to decide who you are,
what you stand for. You can't fool around,
you can't fool yourself. If Israel were like
America trying to rally its allies, would
we like our best friends saying, Well,
there are pros and cons and we've got other
things to think about? He's not saying do
the easy thing. He's saying do the right thing.
You have no sympathy with him, with his views?
The same way that Europe is trying to do the
right thing, but obviously it is impossible to
leave elderly people or children in unheated homes
in the middle of December and January, the same
way Israel cannot leave millions of people prone
to attacks from rockets, from Hezbollah and from
the Iranian sponsored guerrillas in Lebanon and
Syria. So each country wants to join the sanction
regime or to criticize. However, each country has
their priorities to protect their citizens first.
But Rabbi Goldschmidt, Ukrainians are fighting
for their lives and the survival of their unitary
state. And Israel is saying: Yeah, well, it's
terrible, but we've got more important security
concerns to worry about with Iran and Syria.
You said in July: 'Nowadays, the world is
looking at Israel and the Jewish people and
expects us to be on the moral high ground.'
And I'm just wondering whether this position
is the moral high ground you want to occupy.
Within Israel itself, you have a discussion
among-, it might become an issue in the upcoming
elections in November, among political leaders to
what extent Israel should be involved or should
not be involved in this conflict. So Israel,
I would say, is-, right now has taken a
position. Yair Lapid, the current prime minister
of Israel, has taken a position criticizing
Russia. And I want to tell you, Tim, that Israel
has had problems because of it. Russia decided to
close the Jewish Agency. This didn't happen from
one day to the next. There was a reason for it.
Do you regard the changes
in Russia as irreversible,
Rabbi Goldschmidt? Will historians
look back on this, in your view,
as a wrong turn for Russia or the beginning
of a new, dark age in the country?
Right now, I think that Russia is
entering a period of deep isolation,
a new almost totally closed Iron Curtain
with Europe. Not with Asia, but with Europe.
And I think that the coming period
is going to be very difficult.
Do you foresee ever going
back? Do you want to go back?
As you know, we have to be optimists. And I
hope that one day I'll be able to get back.
Rabbi Pinchas Goldschmidt, it's been good to have
you on Conflict Zone. Thank you very
much indeed for your time. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you, Tim, for inviting me.